Privacy begins with the patient.
Only they or their designees can consent
to the use of their health information.
There are a number of models for
obtaining this consent.
Using data without asking for
consent is the No Consent model, but
this isn't reasonable or
even legal in most contexts.
In the Opt-out Model,
Consent is assumed, unless
the patient specifically revokes it.
Some HIEs are using that Model,
but it would be very unlikely and
probably not even legal for
a healthcare provider to use it.
The converse is the Opt-in Model,
where no data is shared
unless the patient consents.
If you've ever visited a physician,
you've probably consented to the use
of your data under this Model.
CurrentCare, the Rhode Island HIE
we'll discuss later, uses this Model.
Typically Opt-in is all or none.
So patients can't share some but
not all of their data.
Despite this inflexibility,
at least one study suggests as many
as 90% of patients will
consent under this Model.
The final Model, Opt-in with patient
specified restrictions, provides more
flexibility and would probably be the
preferred method if it can be managed.